[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
what way wow we got anthony lee back
anthony lee
anthony anthony
you look like a like a triad member uh
try it yeah or like uh you look like no
you look like it man that's what it is
oh man i was like you look like a movie
poster right now
like i'm about to bust out my wing chun
yeah i could be a smooth criminal
yeah always done annie are you okay
and are you all right yeah yep are you
okay
are you having kids anytime soon oh here
he's not even married yet
well you've been yeah axed already maybe
in five years is it part of the
five-year plan
are you a planner you got stuff to do i
think i i i am a planner
in that i like kind of put things into
the universe
for my own kind of like affirmation of
trying to get there
yeah manifesting it but if i don't even
like remotely get there i like don't
really like
regret anything how do you do that oh
that's really cool so he's saying he
might not have kids
i want kids i want he can't say like but
he seems like flexibility
he's flexible i want kids and i want to
have him within the next five years but
i also like am
just maybe reasonable enough for my own
expectations that i've like witnessed
close people around me that like really
really try to have kids and like don't
get them
you know like they [ __ ] hella hard
yeah for like years they're like trying
to have kids or something concerning
things or missing you tell them to stop
doing bukkakes and like actually
do it the right way yeah do you think
that they're doing too many bukkakes
though i don't think that that's the
case
okay i never really thought about that
i'll think about that for everybody that
previously yeah that's what i always
tell my friends
where i'm hopeful that i can have
children as well you seem reactive you
should grow proactive too
define active i don't know like exercise
twice a week or something three times a
day
with your sex are you asking me if if
his sperm is very potent
well how's he gonna know who means no
sperm is potential
what does potent sperm taste like and
enlighten us
uh so it tastes like ionized steel
pineappley there you
come on dude smells like bleach but it
tastes like ionized proteins
okay don't no don't make that face
anthony are you scared though because
you have a lot of cats and as someone
with a lot of cats you have a lot of
cats he just has two
i have two well but that's a lot of cats
i gotta say his cats are crazier than
our cats
they are crazy oh yeah they're wild cats
his cats are great cats have to do with
anything
with his kids you already are taking
care of this thing so are you a little
apprehensive about taking care of
something else well when we entertain
the conversation of things like dogs as
well like
in our future because i also love dogs
and i hope we get a dog one day what
kind of duck
you know what she really wants a golden
retriever oh they're so cute i like
those they're great
very very cool they die quick i have to
say really start all the goldie owners
not like 10 like at least 10 years yeah
man i swear though
my all in my family it's been eight
years max
maybe it's because it's your family oh
damn like
meaning like the way that they take care
of the dogs like the food that they
choose
they're not my favorite not my favorite
maybe they give them kibbles and bits
instead of
wilderness no no they give them the good
[ __ ] gravy train
you know they're taken care of that's
scientific okay i think the idea of
having
a lot to take care of um does
make me feel like i might be held back
from accomplishing
unknowns that i still want to have for
myself what do you want to do in life
still fly airplanes to answer that's
hard but like for example let's take the
cats back into
example right like right after this i
need to make sure that i eventually get
home because i gotta feed them exactly
so like the freedom you guys everybody
knows that right the freedom to just be
like
anything can happen organically if like
joe's just randomly hey
here's another thing you want to go try
this thing it's like i wouldn't be able
to do that because i'm tied down to that
that's what i missed tying yourself down
to pets and then maybe more pets or than
children or whatever like
it's not to say that that's not
something i also want to experience but
like at what
capacity i'm allowed or i'm allowing
myself to still do things
i don't know until i get there that's
why i'm kind of glad my dogs died
because i used to have to go home every
four hours but no i don't have to
anymore there you go
you don't have how often do you have to
go home protector well if it's like
the grandma's taking care of them right
then you know but like before it was
like
even with taiko gotta go home so we just
like everything like
the disneyland four hours gotta bounce
like there's no
like family trip like everything is just
four hours gotta go back home unless we
bring them with us
and then one of them is very violent so
it's not that we could eat in a cafe
outside because that's what's trying to
bite
everything else so for us we're really
trying to pump the brakes on getting a
dog immediately i think like
after we moved to vegas we're going to
chill out and probably enjoy it for like
a year
and then get a dog because it does tie
you down and you don't know
cactus you sure a succulent you don't
have to go home on time for that one so
yeah but you do have to take care of it
unfortunately i do find that you can
kill them
yeah you can it's unfortunate it's hard
succulents yeah when a second one dies
too it's like a kind of like
it sucks like you [ __ ] up it's also an
accomplishment
because they're they're really easy to
take care of so it's like wow i really
had to [ __ ] this
dude our cats can stay alone for up to
three days what
oh sorry dry food sorry yeah dry food oh
yeah automatic feeder automatic feeder
they have their water the only reason
why it's three days
it's because they're kitty litter and
you see that's like
the max i have to clean that every night
no we do
we do too but like if we're gone we can
push it for three days
the maximum stop using that they'll
they'll stop using the kitty litter
after three days and start shooting
everywhere they'll [ __ ] piss up my
one
my morpheus will piss on the bed
immediately no ours too that's why all
the doors no but ours kills [ __ ] on our
bed so we have to close the doors
to our bedroom which one because i have
four of them so yeah
they'll do all kinds of [ __ ] the crazy
cat guy yeah [ __ ] crazy cat what are
your kids are like what do they do
i know one of them pees the rest of our
miracles they're all miracles except for
how many do you have like 20 i have four
cats but i used to have seven
because we were fostering cats but then
we failed at fostering so we had to keep
two of them because i fell in love with
both
and so didn't you have four cats now you
would have kept all seven
you're damned right eye would have and
nikki was like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you and i'm like i don't
know i need therapy let's just get more
cats we'll figure it out later
i thought she would be the cat one yeah
you're the crazy cat
i'm the crazy cat guy for sure nikki
wouldn't have kept as many cats
it's it's because of me we have this
many yeah i sometimes pretend like i
don't like cats because nina but then
like i can't
wait why wait what do you mean she just
loves him so much so sometimes i pretend
like i don't like because i want her
attention but whatever
oh do you and nina like already talk
about like bucket list things that you
guys want to do
before you settle down settle down i
don't even know if i'm impressing those
things on her too
like hard and then she just agrees with
me yeah because like
she's like still finishing up like her
doctorate at her school
in terms of like life experiences right
regardless she she's definitely younger
than me she's like 28 now
right but like how old are you 34. okay
yeah
but um like she hasn't because like
she's still finishing her doctor she
hasn't even gone out to like figure out
with her doctor what to do about it get
her first job you know everybody [ __ ]
gets their first job after college or
whatever it's like
it's your first for a reason it's not
you're like last you know what i'm
saying you end up like finding things
about yourself and moving on so i just
feel like
for me i get to more selfishly think
about what i still need to do
versus impressing upon like the bucket
list items that i think we should do
because she hasn't even like
done her yet you know what's our bucket
list thing for you
and that's also cool that you identify
two different tracks
and it's not like your tracks are
dependent it's not like i'm up to here
you're not here you know it's like hey
this is your journey it's my journey and
we have our journey that's pretty cool
says the guy who's
trying to convince her to go to vegas
right well you do know better so you
know
what's a bucket list thing damn i do
want a dog uh eventually that's
that's a bucket list thing sorry i
thought it was great for you
no i just i have i don't know anthony
we're buds i just
held you to a higher esteem than just
again i'm gonna get a dog we'll see
yeah he knighted you earlier today yeah
come on i [ __ ] knighted you a dj
legend what's your reason to not get one
because i have a solid one
my husband's allergic and i want a dog
so [ __ ] i was allergic to cats so we
got the hypoallergenic ones
there's hypoallergenic dogs
like what the skin the furless one
savannah what kind of cat you got okay
bengals they're hypoallergenic oh
they're loud dude dude these cats are
wow they're fun
it's impressive next level maybe i'll
get a kid they [ __ ] are so smart
like morpheus is trying to like close
open the door to go he like can full
he can fully turn the doorknob so that
so that when we come home and we unlock
the door we don't turn the door handle
when we unlock it it's already open
because that's what opened it yeah no he
can fit or both of them can fetch
wow they play set okay well okay we want
to get extra
extravagant i want to go to all those
major cultural
annual events around the world oh cool
whether it be like the holy festival
the tomatino uh in spain you know i've
done the bowl around already
did you run it yeah you were in there
how close was the bowl
[ __ ] greatest things i've ever done
in my life what the [ __ ]
they give you pamphlets right before you
run that are like these uh
folding things what everybody's like
warming up and get ready in the morning
on the cobblestone
and in the pamphlet it talks about how
you can die and what holy [ __ ]
and that like if you're in here you're
like willingly accepting the fact that
you can die
uh and that uh most people oftentimes
will like when they get scared they like
try to like crouch down and they tell
you not to do that because many people
in the past have been impaled
and then they also tell you in there
that uh the most uh important thing to
watch out for is not necessarily the
bulls but the people next to you
because you like run on the side even
the people who aren't running they'll
like push people back in
whoa but the funny thing is the bull run
is actually only half of the festival
half of the event
if you successfully run the bull run
after the last bull goes into the arena
you have like a certain window of time
before they close the arena doors and
then if you go
into the arena with them then you
participate in the next part of the
festival which is actually the more
intense one oh
[ __ ] yeah where you're in the ring
you go into the bullpen and then what
they do is they release young bulls one
one at a time that have corks on the
horns and the course never stay
oh they put questions and then it's uh
that's why people carry newspapers it's
because when the bull gets in the ring
and everybody's there and the bulls
running around trying to just kill
everybody
it's good luck for the year if you can
touch or slap the bull
ring and then the ball is [ __ ]
running around and everybody's going
crazy
trying to touch it but at the same time
not trying to get
can i bring a pool needle it's the
sickest [ __ ] did you touch the
were you in there right was the
newspaper like to touch it
to slap it yeah wait did you finish the
initial
second part too i was i did both it was
it was very stupid uh
college [ __ ] that you know like when you
go study abroad you're just like
invincible for whatever reason
are you tired looking ugly as [ __ ] like
me
well guess what they're looking good
thank you
because these days curology has made me
beautified this video is brought to you
by curology thank you very much for
making me a beautiful human being
because a couple of years ago i was sad
and i had the uh uh i had the ugly
disease
honestly though before i got on social
media yeah i wasn't as
self-conscious about my skin right
you're not seeing yourself every day
and then before when we were the only
ones on social media like it was very
self-conscious but now everyone has an
instagram account everyone has a tick
tock whatever
so more than ever i think people are
like oh how do i get my skin better i
want it to look good on
cameras yeah i think and you start
noticing a lot of stuff too like
now everyone's on instagram so like now
everyone is noticing like oh [ __ ] we
gotta do
better with this and you can do
something about it
and back then i just like rinse my face
with water
and i didn't really like do anything
else and
you know i would see people with very
flawless skin and i'm like how'd you get
that man it goes oh i got a dizz i got
this dot and i'm like oh that's too much
thinking i can't do that anymore too
much but with curology it's kind of cool
because
they do the thinking for me and i just
went on
and i was like these are my goals man
i'm trying to not get some acne
i'm trying to have not some dry skin
hook me up
and then a licensed provider was like no
worries this is what you need
and boom i got a formula that was custom
for me it says joe that's dope and
what's also cool is they have
a bunch of other products too like acne
body wash
so in case it's just not on her face
sometimes you get pimples on your
shoulders on your back you can wash it
and they also have emergency patches
so if you're trying to go to like an
emergency date or you're trying to take
an emergency picture and you're like oh
[ __ ] what the hell how do i make this go
away
makes it go away thank you curology and
uh me
i actually do not like going to the
store so i
like subscription products where i'm
like yo i know i'm gonna do this like
i'm gonna use this soap
i'm gonna use whatever just send it to
me and
this is what's awesome is the
convenience behind it all yeah so if
you're ready for healthier
or more beautiful skin go to
curology.com
off the record for a free 30-day trial
which is insane she's got to pay for
shipping and handling
go to curology.com off the record for a
free 30-day trial and get your skin
more beautiful and maybe they can they
can help you with the ugliness
like they help me but you get mad [ __ ]
still
but still man my skin my skin is what
helped me
today's video is brought to you by green
chef
and you know i've been on this whole
keto diet thing
right and the thing is it's difficult to
always go online and look at delicious
things it just
takes time because you gotta write down
all the ingredients you need you gotta
go to the market you gotta go i need
this i need that
and if you're living alone like me you
know that buying all these groceries
can kind of be expensive because you buy
like 200 worth of stuff
and you're like all right that's for one
meal for one meal
and then you got to eat that one meal
for the whole week
yeah but then you want variety and all
this stuff and it's cool because with
green chef everything is
pre-packaged it is measured out they do
the thinking for you
and it's delivered to you and check this
out
i'm gonna show you a little thing really
quick they got this gluten green free
it's really cool keto meal right there
oh my goodness and i've been doing that
for being more plant-based and more
whole foods and eating fresh
ingredients instead of going to my usual
bag of chips that's what i really like
about them is that they have one for
all kinds of diet lifestyles so if you
and your partner don't eat the same
thing one person's vegetarian one
person's paleo or a keto or they want to
eat this
they can have all have all those recipes
so you can choose
so you're not limited to just one thing
or the other and which is really awesome
so
if you want to avoid food waste like
joey for single like him or you guys
just don't eat that much everything is
pre-packaged so go to greenchef.com90
off the record because right now you get
90
off plus free shipping that's a lot
that's a lot
greenchef.com90 off the record again 90
bucks off plus free shipping right now
go there and get yourself some yummy
foods
it's delicious what's it like before it
starts like 30 seconds before
are you with the next guy and you're
just like the running part of the
vacation
like no the whole thing the whole bull
run the thing
30 seconds before they they yeah what's
that like like are you [ __ ] just
holy [ __ ] yeah you're just in uh you
just pick an area because the
cobblestone was like this 90 degree run
right it's maybe like a quarter mile
with their bulls go out and there's no
way you can outrun a bull like anything
that you even think you're [ __ ]
possible there's no [ __ ] way you can
outrun them so you just
choose an area of the track that you
want to be okay uh and on the side
everyone chooses the side that best well
i did a lot of like random studying and
stuff like that because i didn't want to
like
die and the thing is the cobblestone is
apparently really slippery so everybody
says or the natives say that when the
bulls turn the corner often times the
bulls like will slip because they're
sprinting
on the part where they're gonna hit yeah
so instead if you can like right at the
corner
let's say this is where they all slip if
you actually end up staying like right
here
then while they're running because
everybody no matter what is going to get
passed by the bulls or hit by them right
once you're right here if they like
start slipping this way and you start
running then there's a better chance
that they'll just kind of like pass you
and then you can get in
oh good how many people died on that run
that you were on
rarely people died but but the the year
before i went there
two non-spanish people ended up dying so
it was like
a renewed sense of like uh yeah just
kind of like everybody on edge
but at the end of the day people still
want to do this [ __ ] right at least
nobody's surprised if you die running
i know right yeah it's like yo what
happened to him he was running with the
bulls oh that makes a lot of sense
it's it's amazing but after experiencing
that i was like there's there's so many
cultural festivals around the world that
are similar to things like that
that i would love to experience i just
had a way more chill time at the lantern
festival
the the lighting one the vegas one yeah
it was really chill
i i also you know do that yeah it was
just way less stressful
yeah that was hard because like there
was a big line and then you're like oh
wait do you take visa
okay cool yeah it was holding everything
to get back to the spot
yeah there's like a tomate or something
like that in spain where
it's the biggest food fight in the world
tomato
like yeah millions of pounds of tomatoes
and they just have a giant
food fight of tomatoes and everybody
literally is swimming in tomato juice
and you're just chucking together i want
to do
holy too that looks so holy the
have you heard of the water one in
thailand where they have a huge water
fight
cool define water fight like they have
super soakers and hoses
oh [ __ ] super suckers a huge water fight
that's like traditional huge cultural
stuff they like have these nerf super
soakers
they have like the nerf like water packs
the backpacks that they're just oh [ __ ]
those were the [ __ ] rich kids man the
best dude
or even even things as simple as like
mardi gras you know what i mean
and just that is a cultural thing yeah
yeah totally yeah it was all
i was there but i was too old i think
because it was too loud and too sticky
like i want to go yeah back to the hotel
i was 30 so i was just it was
it was too i was aged out of it i still
want to experience that even though i
probably feel the same way
it was really cool it was really cool
but like at the same time i was a little
annoyed by all the noise and like all
the enthusiasm what about burning man
would love to would love to go even now
it's all like [ __ ] up with influencers
it's
corporate uh i i didn't have those
feelings but
i still would love to go what about
olympics
yes yes i've been to a couple i've been
to like a couple
uh yeah yeah the olympics i've been to
like in like tokyo imagine like being in
tokyo when the olympics actually
happened i think that would be the
sickest [ __ ]
you buy like one ticket and you see you
get to walk around and see all the
events is that how that works
i don't know or do you have to buy
different items i've been to the pan
american olympics
oh cool how was that like that was cool
in guadalajara and how what did you what
can you answer the question uh i said it
was cool
no but can you buy a ticket to
everything oh i didn't hear that part oh
do you get one ticket and can you like
watch swimming and basketball and like
discus
you have to get tickets for individuals
how much money they do i saw swimming uh
like in this
yeah the swimming ones i don't even know
what the [ __ ] that makes sense because
then certain games are way more popular
than the other ones
yeah and it's never as fun being at a
sports game unless you know the [ __ ] out
of that sport
because then when you're on tv it's like
oh they explain everything but then when
you're there it's just like
swimming that's why this is just kind of
like the simple games are more
digestible it's like oh that guy's
faster than this one
oh yeah that got one he was fascinated i
can tell
there's a reason why it's empty during
swimming i think true i think you're
right
i'm also assuming there might be like a
giant type of like fiesta like during
like dia de los muertos like in mexico
so i would also
like the monarch the monarch butterflies
event thing like when
there's like the migration of the
monarch butterflies that's something on
my bucket list that's mexico too in
mexico
yeah you know um traveling during the
pandemic and stuff it feels like i'm in
one
place still it doesn't feel like it's
because we're all connected by the
pandemic right so we have to wear the
masks and whatever
so it doesn't feel like i'm in a
different place it's culturally bridged
through the culture of pandemic
yeah yeah it's crazy transcended past
everything
coughs brought us together just like
barbed wire could
when you guys were in hawaii right did
you feel like you were in a different
different place still yeah because it's
hawaii man
it was gorgeous but is it masked
everywhere and all that stuff it was
it was i mean yeah like we'd be walking
down the street we're still wearing our
mask or even wearing our mask when we
get to the beach trying to find our
place but then once we're there we set
up and we're in and out of the water
and i forget that it's pandemic did you
just swim with the mask on
i just said pandemic time no but they're
more
um like what do you call it like strict
with the math stuff
yeah like not like that they enforce but
more people do it there
yeah more contact crazy stuff like the
the restaurants and stuff like they make
sure they they check but not in waikiki
where we were
because there was a lot of tourists that
were like [ __ ] your rules and they'd be
walking down the sidewalk like whatever
but we're like come on
there was a guy with the [ __ ] masks mask
on
and like uh he was probably he had a
mask on them
that's what protesting is it's like i'm
still participating but
[ __ ] you unless it was the ones with the
holes
oh yeah that's fine yeah but no i mean i
still felt like
cool we're we're somewhere else because
of the beauty like it's just
why it's so beautiful it's the beautiful
no i didn't it didn't feel the same for
me it was
tripping me out my head was like damn i
know i'm here but i don't feel like a
hundred well the more you travel
that doesn't it the world feel a little
smaller the more you travel
yeah if the excitement of being
somewhere else kind of lessens and it
kind of sucks
you know like it's like you find the
similarities of a lot of yeah so the
effects of traveling more
kind of takes away from each travel you
do yeah but sometimes
sometimes the effect of that like means
you
don't want to be at home as much you
know what i mean like there's
when you go somewhere and you're like
this is better than my home in this way
not necessarily everything of course you
love home for what it is you know but
there's like certain things that make
sense
even when i went to vape and went to i
was just in vegas like
just walking around the casino even
though everyone's like like distant
messed up everything just feeling
everyone's energy again i was like thank
god
because i'm not home right now what
about when it becomes your home
when vegas becomes your home oh even
better
because he's like do you smell that tax
free in the air
it's not cigarettes baby free there i
don't know that's crazy
oh wait i'm throwing this money into the
freaking craps table but it's
tax money baby i like the separation of
the suburbs and the strip
which is kind of cool because the strip
the energy that i get from the strip is
let's go you know like that's like i can
get to
vegas dead tired because i just drove
like five hours and arrived to like
midnight
but the minute you walk in a casino
you're like do you think you'll get that
you while living there i don't know but
like it's separated from the suburbs so
we're near this
i don't even know i'm in vegas i just
feel like i'm in the southwest the
suburbs are suburbs yeah
it's like you're in arizona or something
you know why i think i will
because me and nikki are considering
getting an inflatable jacuzzi right now
so there's no way i'm not trash enough
to think that the vegas strip is still
incredible
yeah like i think it's in my blood yeah
it's your culture yeah i still don't
think inflatables trash i think that's
luxury to me that's why we're friends
wait it's trash that's what i'm saying
this is why we're all friends
[Music]